please criminalize harmful content the
idea that TV can Inspire change saw
winners at the back to Television Awards
making pleas to those in power Kate
Winslet emotional after winning best
actress for an improvised film about the
dangers of social media to any young
person who might be listening who feels
that they are trapped in an unhealthy
world please ask for help while
Anne-Marie Duff used her win for a show
about domestic abuse to speak to victims
television is a profoundly political and
important Arena we're in people's homes
we get to whisper in their ears if
there's anybody watching this tonight
who has someone in their life who is
bullying them who is telling them that
who they are is wrong that what they are
isn't enough who's told at their voice
shouldn't be heard I'm telling you now
you are everything and please stand up
and scream at the top of your lens bad
sisters Dairy girls and reality show the
traitors all picked up two Awards each
while best actor went to and we're sure
for this is going to hurt
a celebration of The Best of British TV
at odds with the writer's strike
currently stopping production on shows
in the U.S it all begins and ends with
the writers so we're in solidarity to
our wga brothers that's very kind and it
wasn't just TV royalty picking up prizes
the Queen's tea with Paddington won the
only award voted for by the public the
good old British voting public you see
sometimes they do get it right
person who most deserves this award is
no longer with us to receive it we can
only accept it on her behalf and say
thank you Mom for everything
from Derry girls to a cameo from a
monarch the awards highlighted a diverse
range of programming the message from
bafta that everyone's stories are
welcome on British TV Claire Gregory Sky
News